alright so we're talking about ethnicity
and who came in first as the Catholics
here I'm American so the fresh you know
they were they were predominately
captain we've talked a little bit about
the French Huguenots for French we got
absorbed by the Dutch most French
speakers here you know on the American
continent where the Catholic because
France is a Catholic nation and they
mostly be concentrated we're just a
couple of places that would matter for
the United States where would you find
French people after it expands of course
like st. Louis you know but before that
where would you find French people the
french-speaking yeah and the entire area
of Louisiana right because those are the
Acadians they got moved out of acadia
and cages no more else here to go due
north of here what would you run into
montreal and that's part of yeah now
neighborhood a little bit more part of
the province of ya go back and put back
as the french-speaking part of canada
there's other parts you know there's
crushed figures in other parts and along
the border with Canada in New England
you have a lot of French lawyers there
was a lot of back and forth across the
border so for a long time these were
really yet as far as you know major
Catholic presence that who comes in who
emigrates here who's the first big wave
of immigration as far as Calkins going
to hit the shores yeah very good so we
have the Irish and we're going to see
the Irish have a different attitude
towards things that
the other ethnicities and at first you
know it's mainly fresh hierarchy bishops
in charge and then you know the Irish
get their own representation then who
else comes in who are the other big
Catholic ethnicities yeah yeah now
they're going to come in down wine who
else yeah Jerris German this yep we have
a lot of Catholics represent it with
just these four ethnicities but who else
there's one other really big one yeah ah
they asked a different part of the story
because for the most part they're coming
up well they're not really first America
takes over large Spanish speaking
territories right and these the
mexican-american war but then there's a
lot of immigration coming up later
you're that's a part of the story that's
going to get told a bit later on well
who else is coming through all this i
foolish very good yes we have polish and
then there's like a smattering of other
things there's people from Bohemia you
know nowadays we call that the Czech
Republic you have Lithuanians you have
some in other areas Portuguese were here
for a long time but they were never
really that that big of a population so
they didn't leave that babe embark so
why do the Irish immigrated here who are
they looking for what are they getting
away from any of you have Irish heritage
there was a lot of that yeah they you
know the English dominated the items and
and treated them pretty pretty poorly a
lot of Ireland was like owned by
absentee neighborhoods yeah yeah the
potato crop fail and the potatoes were
the major form of food major starch
source and once that failed
widespread hunger they actually have the
opportunity to alleviate that but the
British deliberately decided not to ship
weep over to Ireland they made a policy
of that and so a lot of Irish came over
here and they process you know through
gradually Ellis Island became the place
that you went through because Americans
started realizing a lot of people want
to come here so we have to do it in an
orderly way the enviros have their own
particular peculiarities when it comes
to Catholicism so your book talks about
the immigration then they talk about
some of the labor dynamics so as many of
the Irish were poor and illiterate but
they spoke English that's different than
these other groups right if you're in
Ireland you may speak with a Brogue but
you probably do speak English so it's a
little bit easier to fit in their
competition for available work at what
seemed to the indigenous Protestant
working class for very low wages created
a resentment that was a major score to
outbreaks of nativism nativism takes
takes different forms but it what did
what it is you know when we talk about
being anti-immigrant that's nativism and
there was actually a political party
that formed at the time called a
know-nothing party they were called the
know-nothing party because you know when
you do something wrong suddenly nobody
knows anything nobody knows who did it
and they were doing things like
attacking immigrants you know writing
doing you know that that sort of stuff
and it got tied in with anti-catholicism
as well as anti-irish I made a mention
the book how the Irish became white a
little bit earlier because the Irish
when they first came in and we're not
considered to be white by the Native
Americans who at that time didn't mean
what we call Native Americans now but
meant the white anglo-saxon Protestants
in the North primarily they called me so
more Americans because they had this
sense that they were the ones who the
longer so the Irish priest
religious persecution not only in
England but also over here what the book
says one of the best opportunities for
upward mobility in the Irish American
community was to be a priest to become a
parish priest because it meant that you
would get to go to school I meant that
you would have some Authority your book
talks about the vocations encouraging
vocations irish-american Catholicism
became sort of normative in America
during the middle and later 19th century
um and your book talks about that is
having some some specific traits so the
institutional church and clergy enjoyed
great prestige that's going to be
different than some of these other
ethnicities institutional church means
like the hierarchy the race of Bishops
those are those people it also talks
about an ethos in which clerical
celibacy marital fecundity and a general
distrust of sexuality with prevailing
emphasis so very strongly against the
body you know sex is only for
procreation but you should procreate an
awful lot that was a major emphasis
there another book talks about a
devotional revolution what are what our
devotions if you're devoted to somebody
what does that mean to you what does it
mean I love you have boyfriends and
girlfriends right the only times day is
one pass but what would you do show your
devotion or didn't you I hope you did
but now we're far enough along that you
know if you didn't then you probably you
know that's behind you what is devotion
or think about this what is it in terms
of religion does it mean just showing up
at church how can you tell the people
we're really devoted from the people who
are just kind of lukewarm like what
everything I have into it you're like I
loving do extra okay that's a good way
to put it they do extra yeah when you're
dedicated yeah devoted and dedicated
kind of to synonyms devotions are
particular ways of doing that so rosary
for example is a Catholic devotion
interestingly you can see some
Protestants have started doing it you
know in recent years thinking that there
must be something interesting there the
Jesus Prayer for Eastern Orthodox is a
devotion saying the Liturgy of the hours
is a pretty time consuming devotion
there would be a number of other
examples if we're doing a comparative
religion class so we could talk about
with other religions so the devotional
revolution takes place what they mean by
that is the devotional life gets kind of
standardized the Rosary was not
originally something that everybody was
doing it was just one out of many
different devotions it became more and
more popular it ended up supplanting
some of the more local devotions some of
the less prevalent ones and it was like
the book says the roundish was part of
an attempt by both Rome and the Irish
hierarchy to strengthen the
institutional church so that's the story
of the Irish when we look at the Germans
we see a very different story in Ireland
everybody was pretty much one of three
things you're Catholic you were
Protestant and you would probably be a
Presbyterian because you'd be you know
scots-irish from the north or you just
weren't anything Germany was a whole
different
you know environment because there you
had Catholics Lutheran's reformed all
living side by side with each other you
also a lot of Jews in Germany at that
time and you had free thinkers you know
we talked about religious liberalism you
know the people who who were documented
to say Trinitarian Christianity or who
are deists any good outright atheists
from time to time so German Catholics
already grew up in a pluralistic sort of
environment that was lacking to the
Irish and the Germans economically were
in a different condition as well like
your book says they tended not to be as
near destitution as the Irish they were
able to get themselves farmland that's
why the Germans settled in the Midwest
because farmland was very cheap and if
you had just a little bit of money you
could buy yourself the tools and get
yourself out there so your book talks
about the German triangle delineated by
Milwaukee so in the North st. Louis in
the west and Cincinnati in the East they
tended to keep to themselves and they
prefer to continue speaking German so as
opposed to the Irish who could
assimilate once they got you know past
problems on say poverty fairly easily
the Germans tended to stay hard it's
from the rest of American society why
because they had a different language
they had a different culture they wanted
to preserve a german-speaking
environment and that stayed that the
same until the First World War when we
actually fought Germany that was the
main impetus to him to getting rid of
that now german-speaking Catholics like
your book points out we're worried about
this issue of Americanization how much
do you adopt your ways to the new
society that you're in how much do you
adopt your religion Germans done it to
be more conservative in that sense and
your book talks about one of them
presenting a petition to the post
looking for diocese and parishes that
were based on nationality rather than
geography so that everybody could keep
their own ethnicity if we look at the
polish they're kind of in the same boat
although the polish are not coming from
quite a pluralistic society there's a
number of different polish on clouds
palacios that then rise again largely in
the Midwest does anyone here know where
the biggest Catholic popular the biggest
polish population outside of Poland is
Indians it's in a Midwestern City large
enough that even in the last polish
election they set up polling booths for
people who had polish citizenship yeah
yeah Chicago is a huge polish population
and northwestern Indiana a lot of those
those industrial cities have a large
polish population they settled in some
of the same places as the Germans they
wanted well your book calls charity of
representation why was this initiative
well the Irish were there before and
once the Irish you know it sort of
supplanted the French in the English as
the largest group and had priests and
bishops in place these other ethnicities
would come in and they you know they
didn't really trust the Irish to have
their best interests at heart and it
said we want to have our own Greece we
want to have our own representatives you
know among bishops and it took a while
for that to happen like your book says
they had only token representation in
the higher levels until late into the
present century and one washing of this
was the Polish national catholic church
they actually split off from the main
roman catholic church and form their own
very small but if it's still around
organization which is you know more or
less along the same lines they kept the
liturgy at seven polish of course but
they wanted to have their own their own
autonomy you can say and then we have
the italians and your book talks about
some really interesting things with this
italy is divided into regions it wasn't
one unified country yeah the biggest
tension is between the North and South
the South tends to be more poor leading
to a more agricultural less less
well-developed the north is where a lot
of the centers of power work and within
the Catholic Church this dynamic was
represented so the southern Italians
were used to northerners dominating the
church hierarchy most of the Popes that
were Italian were not Italian in the
sense of coming from anywhere in Italy
they were from North Italy so who was a
debt that actually leaves for the United
States there was the poorer Italians in
the South they come here and they've
already got a well established pattern
of not trusting the hierarchy because it
doesn't seem to be coming you know
something that's consonant with their
own needs something that's that's going
to draw on their their experience and
they find themselves in a religious
situation similar to the one that they
leave behind only instead of the North
Italians it's the Irish that control a
hierarchy that that are providing the
priests and they don't feel that well
represented so leads to this very
different kind of pattern where like it
says there was there is an alienation of
many Italians from the institutional
Church some defections are brought about
by proselytizing but a simple absence
from the church except get rights of
passage what would rites of passage for
Catholics being you know baptisms
funerals weddings the occasional going
to to confession that sort of thing was
more than norm and they would continue
to have street festivals but you've got
this kind of split personality their
their ethnic Lee Catholic but they're
not going to church is Lofton there's a
different type of devotion among these
different groups and each of these
represents a different face of
Catholicism in the nineteenth and
twentieth century that doesn't really
gel together until later on so now we
want to look at that part of the story
how did all these come together and that
has to do with this question of
Americanization so your book talks about
a few key issues one is called the
trustee situation weren't one of
trustees you guys have a board of
trustees here at marist you know what
they do of him you're never going to see
him most likely unless you know you're
called upon to beat down or something
yeah don't make decisions yeah what kind
of decisions for the entire school yeah
that's right they make the big quote you
know decisions largely have to do with
with what would you say money exactly
with finances so you know how much
certain groups get paid that's something
that might have to go through the board
of trustees and the trustees would be
the ones who get a Catholic Church would
be in charge of the property because
think about what a church comprises
you've got the actual physical building
right people get in you know
sundays and sometimes now on saturdays
individuals and throughout the week what
do you need to maintain a building you
get a pic of rats if you don't own it
you have to pay property tax if you do
own it you have to pay for lights heats
you know upkeep renovations all that
sort of stuff if you're actually having
sacramental wine and and host somebody
has to buy those two you know you can
run down the list there's a ton of stuff
it doesn't all come come for free it
doesn't all come from donations some of
this has to be administered and that's
what the trustees would do and there
were a lot of questions well who's
actually in charge of the church is it
the priest as the bishop is it the board
of trustees because the trustees might
be there a lot longer than any given
freeze so this is something that they
had to work out and as it turned out
what they decided on was that each
bishop was recognized as a corporation
soul vested property rights in the
church and so that's the structure that
we actually have and this was part of
the batter because some of the people
wanted it to to be late Rusty's that
control the church rather than the
higher rather than the priests and
bishops there's a there's a lot of
discussion here about schools as well
why don't catholics want to have their
own schools just for the uniforms how
many of you want to get why was i don't
i don't want to like out anybody is
particular religion but imagine pride is
probably quite a few of you went to
Catholic school sensor Maris has got a
lot of Catholics what were Catholic
schools about why do they have these
yeah
go to the beach without worrying about
operation that's part of it yeah there
was this notion that if you're going to
teach faith and morals and you think
you've got that right why would you send
your kids to other people who probably
don't have it right and it over to
remember they were using the King James
Bible for a long time as a textbook in
schools and there was quite a lot of
anti-catholicism so it did make some
sense for them to do that school was
also a way for them to assimilate these
massive waves of immigrants we often
overlook the effect that that school it
has if you have a fairly standardized
school system you can make sure that
that children are all are are all
brought up with the same basic idea is
the same basic information and that's
part of the Catholic school system did
your book then talks about with respect
to this Americanization wish it these
three sort of schools of thought and
we're going to find you know there's
different extremes so one extreme would
you call it the conservative the other
one we can call up the radical and then
we're going to have something in the
middle and what a conservatives you know
when you put them scale what are they
usually want things to be like and one
things to change a lot that's
conservative kinda means you know stick
with the same so one group thought that
Americanization should just be rejected
completely and a lot of these were
actually Germans they thought that the
faith could best be preserved together
with the traditional languages and
cultures of Europe so they didn't want
to you know move to an English liturgy
if they can avoid it they wanted to
while they was
the English Virginia is Latin but they
didn't want to carry out things in
English if they could avoid it they
wanted a smaller at the communities so
German Catholics in the main Catholics
Italian Catholics you know so on another
line second group would be sort of a
moderating group and they they wanted
sort of a column address there's some
distrust of Americanization but on the
question of language they were for using
English therefore assimilated in that
sense so in their view German Catholics
should quit speaking German and become
like Americans in that respect none the
radical group they saw Americanization
as a good thing yeah something that
would actually enhance Catholicism here
in America this elect says they saw the
Democratic Athos and policy of
church-state separation not just as a
tolerable option but is a positive good
so they cooperated with other Americans
and as many progressive endeavors as
they could and they actually sort of had
the initiative for quite a while they
were the ones who were sort of leading
the charge in Catholic intellectual life
for a good long time and then your book
talks about how they call that changes
and it talks of a particular word called
the life of father hacker where you've
got this guy and he starts out as a
Protestant and then he becomes a
Catholic and he becomes a Redemptorist
and then he finds that that order is a
little bit too old-fashioned for them
and he found his own order we may have
heard of the policies there are charism
is
to carry out the evangelization of
American Protestants so this book gets a
lot of notoriety and it finally comes
the notice of the Catholic hierarchy and
there's a reaction against this a
reaction against what they call
Americans as a heresy and it was tied in
with things like the trustee question
and whether things should be decided in
the church according to you know
democracy whether church-state
separation is and intrinsic doing all
that sort of stuff and so you know
originally the real dominance is on this
side but its wings over to this side by
the end of the 19th century and then you
see Catholics becoming more and more we
could say institutionally standardized
there's still differences between Irish
Catholics and German Catholics of
Italian Catholics and polish Catholics
but there's this kind of this common you
know sort of ground of opposition to
Americans Asian opposition to modernism
yeah and that doesn't change really
until after back and to which is where
we'll take up the Catholic story once
again